bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo avoir à faire tout le
fil de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjourbonjour michael et cette
semaine notre invité benoît hamon député
socialiste des yvelines bonjour ancien
ministre et candidat à la primaire de la
gauche on commentera cette semaine avec
vous avec d'abord la séquence politique
on va commencer évidemment par ce débat
de la droite deux finalistes à la
primaire de droite au débattue pour la
dernière fois avant le résultat final ce
week-end parmi les moments forts du
débat un échange sur le temps de travail
dans la fonction publique la question de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse a
ressurgi de façon spectaculaire dans le
débat elle s'est même invitée à
l'assemblée où une réunion de commission
a dû être suspendue on parlera également
du débat budgétaire il n'aura pas lieu
au sénat la majorité sénatoriale de
droite refuse d'examiner un texte
qu'elle juge à sa serre l'assemblée
évidemment un dernier mot et on commence
tout de suite par la dernière manche de
la primaire à droite
une passe d'armes a marqué ce débat
c'était sur la question des
fonctionnaires et sur le temps de
travail
écoutez cet échange on en débat juste
après avec notre invité on ne fera pas
dans la fonction publique une réforme
consistant à proposer aux fonctionnaires
de travailler pour des heures 37 ne se
fera pas et bien c'est bien je suis en
désaccord
c'est un point très des paris dont c'est
important les paris parce que ce n'est
pas juste parce que c'est pourquoi c'est
pas juste parce que ce débat je sais
jusqu'à salariés travaillent 39 eur et
pas un fonctionnaire salarié qui va
travailler 30 de varier il va le payer
de 39 heures mais a clairement annoncé
son offre des cas exceptionnels entre
les entreprises
ce n'est pas juste on ne peut pas
demander à des fonctionnaires de
travailler plus pour gagner bois
là c'est différent c'est un point
fondamental parce que ça veut dire en
fait qu'alain juppé ne veut pas vraiment
changer les choses si on veut que le
pays se redresse
il faut que tout le monde fasse un
effort supplémentaire au fonds faut
qu'on travaille un peu plus et qu'on
dépense un peu moins benoît hamon est ce
que ça veut dire que françois fillon et
alain juppé
c'est la même chose pour vous pas sur ce
point manifestement etc indique surtout
la violence qui serait celle du projet
de françois fillon s'il devait
s'appliquer violence will violence
imaginer à l'hôpital passer de 35 à 39
heures payées 35
vous allez demander une aide soignante à
une infirmière toutes celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont déjà sous pression sont
victimes de souffrances au travail à
raison de cette pression de faire cela
tout ça n'est absolument pas lancer un
programme dangereux selon vous un homme
de dieu non mais je pense que c'est
violent et tranquillement benoîtement
presque françois fillon
annonce des transformations qui se
traduiront par de la violence pour
celles et ceux qui vont subir les
conséquences de son projet et quand il
dit on travaille 39 heures dans le privé
pense qu'ils calculent en moyenne en
fonction des heures supplémentaires mais
rochelle que pour le coup on est payé là
non seulement 39 heures mais en plus on
heures supplémentaires ces recrues la
france dans la longère je ne sais pas je
ne préfère pas l'affront du mal à juppé
je dis simplement que en l'occurrence le
projet de françois fillon est d'une rare
violence pour les fonctionnaires à ceux
qui devront vivre les conséquences
depuis ce discours anti fonctionnaires
est vraiment à un moment on a besoin de
protéger les français contre la crise
économique la crise sociale les péril
climatique
le péril terroriste refaire mon état
mois d'hôpital moins de deux professeurs
- de quoi encore c'est tout ça n'est pas
sérieux c'est très idéologue mais pas
très simplement parce que c'est réaliste
c'est ce qu'on pensait qu'ils peuvent
vraiment mettre en application son
programme cinq cent mille fonctionnaires
de deux mois après il va devoir négocier
avec des syndicats
et donc il obtiendra quoi 300 milles où
est ce qu'ils en pensent et ce rien je
sais simplement que s'il fait ça il ne
s'ouvre une période en france car de 2,2
le conflit et de tension qui sera
incroyable voyez les gens se réjouir
quand on disait dans les états-majors de
françois fillon cent mille
fonctionnaires en moins comme si on
donnait en pâture des postes de
fonctionnaires ben moi je vous dis moi
je pense qu'il faut plus d'infirmières
plus d'être soignante plus de
professeurs plus de fonctionnaires là où
justement aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'argent public ce que vous demandez ce
week-end aux électeurs de gauche d'aller
massivement voter nos rencontres
françois fillon non je ne demande pas ça
pas davantage que je demande aux
électeurs de droit de venir à la
primaire de gauche tout on n'est pas
dans une zone aux exercices qu'il faut
respecter moi je respecte la primaire de
droite et je vais même mon seul je salue
n'ayant la réussite de cette primaire
est parfois la qualité des échanges
honnêtement voir oui mais je trouve que
ça avait été peu de bonne qualité pas
surtout à la veille parfois qui met en
valeur les qualités
laissons le peuple de droite où les
français ont verbe est un droit de
choisir leur champion
alors en attendant les deux finalistes
ont donné aussi ce jeudi leur vision des
questions sociales très différentes et
aussi sur le modèle social français
côté de quel modèle social vous parlez
le modèle parler d'un modèle social qui
aujourd'hui génère 6 millions de
chômeurs on parlait d'un modèle social
français qui se traduit par le
déclassement des classes moyennes on a
besoin de changer profondément ce modèle
justement pour qu'il soit plus juste la
principale menace sur le modèle social
français
c'est la politique qui a été conduite
depuis cinq ans et notamment
l'incapacité à maîtriser le chômage
c'est ça la vraie difficulté est ce que
vous redoutez une casse du modèle social
français mouvement irréversible
je pense que dans leurs mots quand il
évoque le modèle social français c'est
pas pour le rendre plus protecteurs il
ya incontestablement une crise du modèle
social français au sens où ils ne
protègent pas correctement du français
parfois contre la maladie parfois contre
les accidents du travail ou les maladies
professionnelles contre la précarité les
inégalités c'est pour ça que je propose
le revenu universel d'existence parce
que ce qui me frappe c'est l'incapacité
de l'un comme de l'autre à anticiper ce
que sera l'impact de la révolution
numérique sur le fait qu'on va
travailler moi le travail va se raréfier
et comment on finance la sécurité
sociale par un travail s'il y a moins de
travail
il ya plus de sécurité sociale à moyen
et long terme si on ne réfléchit pas à
faire payer les robots les machines en
lieu et place des hommes françois fillon
a dit autre chose il a dit que la france
n'était pas multiculturelle que dit
l'élu de trappes
c'est vrai ça combine les luttes rap
même les luttes brest où l'élu de noms
mais je dirais famille nous restions
qu'heureuse et oui mon cerveau mais je
pense que françois fillon ils se
trompent vision mais mais si moi par
exemple je suis breton ça ne me remplit
pas je suis socialiste ça me remplit pas
j'ai été élevé en partie au sénégal ça
ne me remplit pas l'identité c'est une
narration ce qui va là pour moi est
valable pour la nation la vision qu'a
françois fillon de la nation française
elle s'arrête elle c'est comme si
l'horloge s'était arrêté dans une époque
qui serait le bouddhisme du xxème siècle
je ne sais quoi mais mais il ya le refus
de la narration et moi je récuse sa
vision mais quitte une vision mais nous
très vieillotte jeudi elle est très
vieillotte très oui mais trevor l'armée
et de la france de la france elle est
ouvert depuis longtemps sans doute que
cette serre la main trop grave puisqu'on
l'a inspiré mais moi je rêve antique la
république métissée et la république
métissée c'est la france dans laquelle
on vit et même le débat sur les racines
chrétiennes moi j'ai été baptisé donc je
suis catholique de baptême
ça ne me remplit pas non plus et je
refuse aujourd'hui que qu'on renvoie
l'identité de la france à une religion
un morceau de son histoire une couleur
ou une pigmentation de peau
bref tout ça c'est sordide voilà donc il
y aura sordide en tout cas c'est
dangereux de ne pas comprendre que c'est
une narration
donc je trouve que voilà c'est pas ma
france en tout cas était pas votre en
france pour sa meilleure non à votre
stylet il appartient il est une
composante moi je le revendique comme
une composante de la france je ne
rejette pas évidemment que les
traditions les valeurs chrétiennes sont
sont importantes dans la france oui mais
je ne rejette pas cela mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'ils rejettent tout le reste
lui est alors peu avant le débat
politique cette semaine s'est aussi
invitée à l'assemblée allant même
jusqu'à propres provoquer un clash en
commission
une proposition de loi était à l'ordre
du jour de la commission des affaires
sociales pour étendre le délit d'
entrave à l'image et au site internet
eh bien le sujet revenu dans l'actualité
a provoqué une altercation entre députés
le récit de jean baptiste daoulas après
seulement quelques minutes de débat la
discussion sur le délit d' entrave
numérique l interruption volontaire de
grossesse s'envenime ancien quart et
garder la presse messieurs la porosité
qu'il y a entre cherche un jeu demande
vous n'aurez la parole que quand je veux
la donnerez vous êtes inscrit sur les
temps de parole si vous continuez je
vous assure je vous donne encore deux
minutes
les insultes fusent sur les bancs de la
droite monsieur jacquard la séance est
suspendue pendant deux heures et demie
comme denis jacquat les élus les
républicains reprochent au socialiste
d'instrumentaliser l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
dans le contexte de la primaire de la
droite et du centre en écartant les bras
je me vois encore six courses et je
dirais très très très gentil et est
nommé chante et parce que pour moi
pour moi c'est important ça fait très
longtemps que je suis là commission des
affaires sociales le suit depuis
longtemps les textes sur le social et
domaine sanitaire la commission c'est un
lieu de travail c'est n'est pas un lieu
de politique politicienne
mais pour la présidente ps de la
commission aucune arrière pensée
politique dans un calendrier
parlementaire élaboré il y a déjà
plusieurs semaines
rien ne laissait prévoir qu alain juppé
et françois fillon se déchirerait sur
les vg dans la primaire c'est tombé là
parce que la législature se termine et
peu des niches parlementaires des
différents d'ailleurs deviennent moins
nombreuses par définition et le groupe
socialiste l'a mis dans une niche qui va
être le premier des cent le jeudi 1er 10
ans et nous forcément on en discute une
semaine avant conditions là rien
d'extraordinaire
les travaux ont repris en fin de matinée
sans les députés républicains qui ont
boycotté la séance
le délit d' entrave numérique ali vg a
finalement été voté il sera discuté dans
l'hémicycle le 1er décembre
non ça vous inspire quoi ce genre
d'incident on peut plus discuter
sereinement de rien en tout cas pas de
sujets d'actualité comme ça en
commission de tension qui est liée à la
période c'est l'élection présidentielle
mais le sujet de végéta sujet c'est
classe oui mais c'est un d'un clash qui
se fonde sur quoi sur le fait qu'il
existe des sites internet qui vont
donner les informations fausses sur les
berges et qui ne conçoit contre les vg
c'est une opinion je la respecte je suis
radicalement opposées à cette position
mais elle existe et ça a eu personne
n'empeche quelqu'un de dire qu'il est
contre lille et j'aime et que des sites
internet donne des fausses informations
et aux prétextes d'informer sur les vg
en fait on me dira poursuivre un combat
politique
oui le parlement est légitime à dire que
désinformées sur une question aussi
difficile que les vg et des décisions
compliquées pour les femmes ou les
couples qui décident de prendre cette
décision là ça c'est inadmissible et le
parlement est dans son droit il a bien
fait d'agir en ce sens une dernière
question est ce que les lobbys religieux
et notamment anti ivg au prix le pouvoir
est ce que ce sont souvent des réseaux
catholiques
est ce que vous estimez que cette
religion a pris le pouvoir aujourd'hui
oh non je pense pas que le la religion
catholique est prêt pouvoir qu'elle soit
très influent notamment cerné de
réception bien entendu et puis durs les
plus durs vous l'avez vue sur la
campagne de prévention du vih on a une
campagne de prévention sur le sida qui
met en scène quelques photos de couples
d'hommes rien de particulièrement
héroïne merde j'ai supprimé mais voilà
rien de particulièrement choquants dans
les dents les photos elles devraient
illustrer une campagne sur un tout autre
sujet personne ne les aurez remarqué
mais comme c'est sur la prévention du
sida
le lien était naturellement fait avec
l'homosexualité et d'ukrainiens que ces
images jus qui n'ont rien de choquant
justifie d censure de la part d'élus de
droite volution conservatrice où ils
révolution conservatrice on en arrive à
un moment
une partie de la droite sous influence
d'un certain nombre de courants
religieux incontestablement ne n'y vont
pas il y militer l'isi travailler
aujourd'hui disent non nous n'avons rien
à voir avec ça si l'on à voir avec ça ça
tombe de courants religieux intégriste
et conservateurs notamment lié à
l'église catholique très très très très
très loin de ce que dit le pape françois
ce qui me frappe moi aujourd'hui c'est
que ceux qui aux influences et se laisse
ce qui est le débat politique à droite
sont pas du tout du tout du tout en
phase avec l'ouverture au monde
l'ouverture aux autres qui est celle du
pape françois c'est quand même on a de
ce point de vue là une évolution en
france dans la communauté une partie de
la communauté catholique qui est
significative comme dans la vie
politique qui a une radicalisation à
droite quoi benoît hamon a parlé
maintenant du budget notamment des
sénateurs qui refuse d'examiner ce texte
le projet de loi de finances ne sera
donc pas examiné par la majorité
sénatoriale de droite une première
depuis 1993
résumé sonnera cerqueira un budget est
bidon insincère électoralistes voilà
comment la majorité sénatoriale qualifie
le projet de loi de finances pour 2010
est elle compte le rejeter sans même le
faire voter grâce à l'adoption d'une
question préalable
seule la discussion générale aura lieu
le texte repartira donc sans
modification à l'assemblée nationale une
première depuis 1993
les sénateurs n'ont pas à apporter leur
garantie leur caution
les sénateurs n'ont pas à apporter leurs
votes à des mesures électorales qui sont
d'ailleurs des mesures sans lendemain
puisque ce budget ne sera pas exécutée
tout le monde le sait donc pas théâtre
d'ombrés pas de jeu de rôle
de son côté le gouvernement accuse les
sénateurs de droite de refuser le débat
alors que les français veulent savoir
comment sera réalisé le plan d'économies
de 100 à 150 milliards d'euros et il
faudrait nous dire clairement il faut
dire clairement au pays
comment vous comptez faire pour
supprimer de 300 mille à cinq cent mille
emplois publics pour la majorité
sénatoriale
le projet de loi de finance repose sur
des prévisions de croissance irréalistes
ce n'est pas un exercice qui permet au
parlement de se prononcer sur des vrais
chiffres et que aujourd'hui la france
est à la traîne niveau européen
elle est à la traîne en termes de
croissance à est à la traîne en terme de
déficit et donc la copie du gouvernement
et finalement elle est déjà caduc
al'inverse la commission européenne est
plus optimiste
elle voit la france passait en dessous
de la ligne rouge des 3% de déficit
public imposée par bruxelles
un contre argument pour le gouvernement
benoît hamon est ce que vous diriez que
le budget qui a été présenté et sincère
oui il est sincère bois on est là dans
du jeu politique sur les élections
présidentielles la droite dit à l'ats
pas totalement tort ce budget si jamais
on gagne il ne sera pas exécuté donc
elle se met en dehors du débat ayant
peut-être aussi parce qu'ils sont bien
incapables de se mettre d'accord sur la
manière de proposer un contre budget
aujourd'hui entre les jeunes à l'image
c'est ce que voulait dire oui voilà mes
mais peu importe si c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse ce qui ce qui est
intéressant c'est de savoir aujourd'hui
si oui ou non considère qu' il faut
continuer à serrer la vis et à supprimer
je veux dire poser les choses telles
qu'elles sont supprimer des postes
d'enseignants qui est plus de moins
d'adultes dans les écoles et moins
d'adultes ou en tout cas moins de
fonctionnaires dans les hôpitaux sont
salis vrai sujet est là dessus la droite
semble dire oui il en faut moins honte
quand on peut faire avec moi moi je
pense qu'il en faut plus à l'art et sur
le budget qui est venu moi je me suis
abstenu fonctionnaires vous voulez vous
en plus ne cessez pas comme ce n'est pas
comme ça que je dirais je vous avais
quand effectifs non mais je vous donnais
un objectif si par exemple dans
l'éducation nationale on dit que l'une
des priorités c'est la formation
continue la formation et si on donne
davantage de jours où les profs se forme
dont ils ont besoin dans leur carrière
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de formation
continue aujourd'hui en france ça veut
dire qu'il faut bien les remplacer si on
se fixe sur ce qu'on appelle le cycle 2
cp ce1 ce2
un objectif qui niait en moyenne pas
plus de 20 élèves par classe il faut
continuer à des doublés d'eto'o provient
de fonctionnaires c'est pour suivre les
recrutements on en a fait 60 milles de
plus sur un quinquennat il faudra
poursuivre les recrutements dans tous
les secteurs où aujourd'hui on a besoin
de professeurs dans le sait comment vous
financez sénat 0 il est tout simplement
ont continué à avoir des politiques sur
les politiques ou les prélèvements
d'abord sur le capital aussi dans par la
fusion csg ir par la modulation de
l'impôt sur les bénéfices des sociétés
selon qui les font fonctionner la baisse
de la bourse non je remets en cause
d'une partie du cicr parce qu'il est
inutile et que là on gaspille de
l'argent qui pourrait utilement aller
financement d'un service public de
qualité je peux même vous dire les
services publics dont on aurait besoin
qui n'existent pas ce que vous
considérez pas par exemple aujourd'hui
qui auraient besoin d'un service public
de la petite enfance pas seulement pris
en charge par l'état ni les
municipalités mais aussi par des
structures privées avec crèche
associative crèche parentale voire même
crèche d'entreprise
là il y aurait besoin d'un vrai service
public ce que vous considérez
aujourd'hui que quand on paye une
auxiliaire de vie 1300 euros par mois
pour qu'elles s'occupent de nos parents
nom du commanditaire des toilettes à
domicile lui ménage et qu'elle a une
demi heure pour faire la toilette
nourrir faire le ménage etc a dit
qu'elle ne le peut pas c'est acceptable
on voit bien qu'il ya des secteurs dans
lequel il faut développer un service
d'intérêt général sous des formes
peut-être différentes de ce qu'on
faisait avant et de ce point de vue là
moi je suis d'accord a service public ça
peut plus être un fonctionnaire un
formulaire un guichet comme avant donc
réformer quand même ça oui évidemment
évidemment pas ce qu'ils font est
individualisé une partie des réponses
mais moi je pense que c'est pas moins
aujourd'hui de services aux personnes
c'est du service public qu'il faut mais
plus nous fermons si je l'assumé nous
fermons cette séquence parlementaire on
va revenir à cette question maintenant
qu'ils se posent mais que va faire
françois hollande est ce qu'il va se
déclarer candidat à la primaire de la
gauche il a jusqu'au 15 décembre sur la
semaine et stéphane magnan nous explique
ce qu'il peut faire
le chef des socialistes au sénat en
at-il trop dit hier en dévoilant le
calendrier de françois hollande pour
le président de la république a dit
qu'il donnerait sa réponse le 10
décembre c'est les candidats je ne
soutiendrai pas ce qu'il est capable de
porter le bilan de son quinquennat qui a
été décrit tout au long de ce
quinquennat
à gauche comme à droite d'ailleurs parce
que les fraudeurs ne nous ont pas aidés
mais dans ce quinquennat sera
revalorisée j'en suis certain
et j'en suis certain françois hollande a
jusqu'au 15 décembre pour se déclarer
date limite du dépôt des candidatures de
la primaire socialiste et à en croire
les proches du chef de l'état ces
intentions ne laisse plus de place au
doute
moi je n'en doute pas c'est lui qui le
dira oui maintenant tout est plus ou
moins sa candidature
je n'en doute pas en neige douter
françois hollande accélère ses soutiens
occupe le terrain médiatique avec pour
objectif d'éviter au chef de l'état
d'être pris de vitesse par son premier
ministre manuel valls et manuel valls
considère qu'il a aussi des capacités et
qui s'il devait relever ce défi il
pourrait le relever j'en ai parfaitement
conscience et j'ai dit que j'étais je
respecte et ça en même temps il ya un
président de la république et c'est lui
qui a été élu en 2012
voilà donc c'est lui qui décide et c'est
lui qui décide le premier ministre lui
maintient la pression sur le chef de
l'état il déclarait récemment qu'il
fallait de la méthode de la rigueur un
engagement personnel une incarnation et
une autorité pour l'exercice du pouvoir
les relations au sein du couple exécutif
s'annonce donc tendu jusqu'au 15
décembre relation tendue au sein du
couple exécutif je vais sourire pendant
la division ce sujet par côté ce tableau
où tout le monde sait lire foncez lire
on sait interpréter les déclarations des
proches de manuel valls on sait dire ses
interviews il souhaite être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et voudrait
bien comment ils voient bien pousser une
décision défavorable du président de la
république
non mais moi je trouve que cette
déstabilisation d'exécutif venue de
l'exécutif lui-même pose problème c'est
premier ministre qui a dit que nous
étions en guerre c'est premier ministre
qui a réclamé de l'unité l'homogénéité
dans une situation où les français
avaient besoin d'être protégés pas
simplement du risque terroriste
des difficultés qui sont les leurs donc
je trouve cette séquence du point de vue
des deux têtes de l'exécutif pas bonne
et je le dis parce que moi j'ai pris mes
responsabilités je ne suis plus au
gouvernement j'ai décidé de faire porter
ma parole au dehors
comme d'autres mais là nous sommes
devant ce qui relève d'une compétition
entre les deux têtes de l'exécutif
je ne la trouve pas saine voilà est-ce
qu'il fragilise françois hollande tout
cas indiscutablement cette séquence et
ne montre pas un exécutif d'abord
concentré sur sa tâche est en capacité
de 2,2 voilà de nous dire comment on
fait face aux différents rendez-vous qui
viennent donc je veux simplement dire
c'est que nous ils entendent que le
premier ministre voudra bien y aller
soit on a bien compris au maintenant que
rapidement les choses se décantent moi
je peu importe qui sera choisi parmi eux
mais que ça sera l'élu oui mais je
trouve c'est surtout l'un des premiers
ministres le chef de l'état donc quand
on entend de la part du premier ministre
des appels à la responsabilité en
permanence et convoi par série
d'interviews d une envie de
ce n'est pas un coup de le présenter non
ce n'est pas sérieux
oui ce n'est pas sérieux jamais une
question également concernant votre
primaire est ce que vous vous engagez
aujourd'hui à soutenir le gagnant de la
première quoi qu'il arrive côté je les
dis il ya des règles du jeu
j'aimerais quel qu'il soit oui mais quel
qu'il soit et promettez moi une chose
puisque maintenant on est instruit par
l'expérience que vous poserez cette
question-là manuel valls et si benoît
hamon évidemment quand il sera choisi
par les français de gauche le 29 janvier
le soutiendrez vous aujourd'hui les
sessions nombreuses races non mais je le
dis parce que moi j'ai répondu plusieurs
fois et on me demande à chaque fois de
répondre à la même question fils manuel
moi je ne suis pas dans la perspective
de perdre voilà et je vous dis jusqu'au
bout ce que je propose avec constance
sur la question du travail la question
sociale sur la question européenne sur
la question écologique je ne crois j'ai
dit je fus croyants dans la croissance
parce que tout le monde va vous dire cap
sur la croissance fait combien de temps
qu elle n'est pas revenue positions
libérales ou sociale libérale elle ne
revient pas donc se pose peut-être
posons nous la question de savoir quand
on va chercher à demi point de
croissance et que ça se fait au
détriment de l'environnement le
détriment de droit social on pourrait
peut-être penser un modèle de
développement qui soit plus tempérant et
qu'ils soient plus riche en emplois - je
pense que toutes ces solutions sont là
devant nous mais qu'on est toujours avec
les viol au gie ciel et que et que tout
ça mais c'est pas parce que d'ailleurs
on fait un bouquin qui s'appelle
révolution que ce n'est pas pour autant
un vieux logiciels d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que c'est incroyable
je dirige et de communication mais c'est
100% la communication et le titre n'est
que de la communication révolution de
quoi d'arrêter de bosser 35 heures quand
on est un jeune c'est une révolution
croyais tout les oui et les jeunes
startups heures travaillent la nuit soit
mais le monde n'est pas fait que de
start-up heures qu'ils adoreraient
voyager de new york à paris il ya des
gens qui se lèvent tôt le matin et
cantonais après avoir passé en
apprentissage on a un jeune ouvrier
on a besoin aussi de pouvoir travailler
selon le temps de travail qui étaient
fixés pourquoi parce que même pour ces
jeunes là le travail plus pénible se
traduira aussi par piles de maladie et
probablement une espérance de vie plus
courte
ces choses à ce respect doivent gym jara
c'est est avec nous cinq autres
partenaires définir
bonjour dirigeants michael bonjour
quatre chats bonjour benoît hamon a
parlé de la primaire à gauche la
primaire à gauche qui semble un peu au
point mort alors que celle de l'ordre de
droite a été un succès participation on
a entendu arnaud montebourg cette
semaine s'inquiéter des conditions
d'organisation et du retard pris dans
cette organisation
si vous est ce que vous craignez est-ce
que vous avez des craintes sur la tenue
du scrutin
donc j'ai pas de craintes sur la tenue
du scrutin mais ce serait mieux qu'on en
parle effectivement et que le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste lance une
grande campagne pour dire ce que je vais
dire maintenant que c'est le 22 et le 29
janvier qu'on vote cdma ridicule mais
oui c'est dans deux mois que doit donc
il faut populariser cela sinon on pourra
imaginer qu'il ya une forme de de calcul
c'est moins on parle de cette primaire -
y aura des gens pour voter plus à perdre
à part quelques candidats du pouvoir il
reste humble mais sinon on ne pensera et
moi je vais tout faire pour que ce soit
pas le cas en temps je vais vous dire
sur le terrain ça y est ça commence à
bouger et on voit il ya un intérêt mais
leur mise et d'organisation interne
c'est à priori pas réunies pendant un
certain temps la faute à qui écoutez on
était on appris au candidat j'ai vu que
je joue à accabler personne là dessus on
verra maintenant maintenant on rentre
dans la primaire de gauche donc on
pouvait imaginer qu'avec la primaire de
droite s'étaient mezzo voce maintenant
il va falloir faire jouer un petit peu
plus on a les voix de gauche on est
entendu arnaud montebourg appelé les
électeurs de droite à voter à cette
primaire il faut aussi des électeurs de
gauche il s'est un peu repris est-ce
qu'il a commis une erreur selon vous en
en lançant cet appel au jeu
je ne comprends pas en quoi un électeur
de droite pour être un arbitre utile
d'un débat à gauche
voilà je dis les choses simplement pas
davantage que je ne comprenais linverse
donc ils vont faire tomber lensois
hollande concrètement c'est ça l'idée si
on est sûr de ce que l'on défend moi je
pense aujourd'hui que les propositions
que je mets sur la table l'écho qu'elles
sont sur le terrain me permettent
d'envisager sereinement de pouvoir
l'emporter
c'est pas en appelant les électeurs de
droite qu'un projet de gauche à mes yeux
l'emportera sauf voilà donc ce que je ne
le suis pas sur ce terrain là martine
aubry réunit ses soutiens demain à bondy
c'est le carrefour des gauches elle
entend un peu ressoudé les morceaux
d'une gauche complètement éclaté alors
on sait qu'elle n'est pas candidate mais
est-ce qu'elle a une carte à jouer dans
l'après 2010 est sur ce qu'on appelle la
recomposition de la gauche martine aubry
vous mais l'après 2010 est ça commence
ce en 2016 c'est le simplement dire
c'est que c'est faire l'impasse sur la
présidentielle me paraît compliqué et
avant de penser à l'après 17 ce qui
supposerait qu'on est déjà anticipé la
défaite
il s'agit de voir aujourd'hui combien de
français sont capables ou veulent ou
acceptent de se rassembler autour de
propositions simples quand j'ai posé le
revenu universel d'existence qui grandit
dans la campagne je m'en réjouis
on voit beaucoup de gens de gauche et de
2,2 vraiment de toutes les familles de
la gauche s'intéresser à ce qui pourrait
être une nouvelle protection sociale qui
changent notre rapport au travail qui
permet d'éradiquer la pauvreté
bref c'est autour de ces contenus là
qu'on y arrivera d'aucuns moi je suis
vous préfériez quelques l appartement
jusqu'à 20 candidats vous par exemple je
serai très attentif à ce qui se dira sur
le fond ça m'intéresse
après ce qu'elle fera écouter martine
aubry c'est martine aubry on est tous
vous comme moi bien placé pour savoir
que
si elle décide de soutenir quelqu'un le
fera si elle a envie et le fera mais bon
c'est quand moi je fais campagne et je
suis revenu ce jeudi sur la première
vous êtes sûr de gagner cette primaire
aujourd'hui des remontées de terrain
est ce que vous nous dites aujourd'hui
un peu comme françois fillon l'objet
doit garder pas les sondages ce serait
le françois fillon de la primaire de
gauche une ça je ne peux pas être
françois fillon de rien du tout mais je
comprends l'analogie mais ce que ce que
je sens c'est que oui mais je pense que
autour des contenus se passe des choses
voilà et on a on désespère trop souvent
du peuple français de sa capacité à se
retrouver sur des contenus plutôt que
sur des stratégies électorales
incomplètes savait et donc voila moi il
me semble qu'il se passe des choses je
veux dire c'est passé de 48 heures en
normandie
j'en suis revenu
comment dire très motivé j'ai persuadé
de gagner la bourgogne picardie gros
dans les hauts de france parlant de la
maintenance non je refuse je sens que ça
se passe voilà je sens qu'il ya des
queues que si quelque chose chez les
communistes en qu'ils soient en train de
voter en ce moment sur la stratégie
présidentielle ils ont deux options que
candidatures indépendantes ou un
ralliement peut-être un candidat la lgv
vers la gauche
et puis un soutien jean luc mélenchon
qui est l'option soutenu par pierre
laurent est ce que vous souhaitez que
les militants invalides cette option du
soutien affluent avec mélenchon va
d'abord les cadres ont refusé de ce l'on
fait bien chaud c'est la parole est aux
militants oui la parole top non alors la
moindre seconde des militants
communistes
ils font ce qu'ils veulent moi ce que je
souhaite c'est ce que j'aurais souhaité
c'est que jean luc mélenchon viennent
dans la primaire de gauche parce que
j'entends dire oui mais on veut pas se
déroulant dans s'il n'est pas capable de
battre hollande dans la primaire de
gauche il va mal battre aux prêtres des
élections présidentielles puis là on
aurait eu la capacité de pouvoir
rassembler 25 30 % du corps électoral et
donc d'être second tour l'élection
présentielle la division ça nous assure
quasiment l'élimination donc je moi je
militerai quoi qu'il se passe pour d'une
manière ou d'une autre le rassemblement
de la gauche mélenchon inclus eh bien on
t'a vu avec cette phrase là vraiment
c'est à vous merci à tous et bonne
semaine